hello everyone onigiri isn't really
known for winning a lot of his games but
what he is known is for losing very few
of them if you look at his encounters
with Magnus Carlsen for example given
Carlsen played 18 games altogether in
classical time format and Geary won one
game Carlsen won one game and the
sixteen other games were drawn so you
don't just beat onigiri he's a he's an
extremely hard player to beat but this
is round four of the World Cup in
Tbilisi Georgia and in this round the
Giri faces the anomaly he plays against
the Vasilyevich oak and well any any
chess player that ever faced event you
will tell you one thing
you simply can't prepare for event you
because if I'd replace everything and
you want Chuck knows everything so so
let's see this game event chuck is white
and gear is black we have E 4 E 5 Knight
to f3 Knight to f6
so the patter of defense we have d4 and
Knight captures on e4 and you know Gary
playing the better of defense that's
that's like a definition of a draw but
he is playing against divine rook Bishop
to d3 d5 we have Knight captures on e5
and Knight to d7 Knight capture son d7
Bishop captures on d7 and eventual
castles we have disrupted e6 Queen to h5
and this Queen to h5 isn't isn't really
a all I usual move in this position you
replace Queen to f6 now attacking this
d4 pawn and we have Bishop to e3
defending the d4 pawn and also adding
protection to this f2 points or not the
rook can go to e1 give castles Queen
side and we have Knight to c3 attacking
this
d5 pawn and also the knight on e4 twice
gierek captures the knight Knight
captures and c3b captures on c3 and we
have Queen to e6 if I'd replace rook to
e1 + f6 I would have better to d2 now
attacking this Queen and the Queen to g8
is played and we have rook a to be one
eventually puts his rook into B file
assuming this very
nice file we have King to b8 this is
well this is a useful move as it adds
protection world to the a7 phone and
also allows this bishop to go to ca to
add more protection to this b7 pawn we
have h3 and now get replaced b6 as well
now he's pretty much pretty much this
rook isn't a danger immediately but if
I'd replace a bishop to a6 you know this
will constrict to the black King nicely
we have g5 and even to here plays Queen
to f3 and eventually doesn't mind this
g4 idea I want to invite to give it to
play it and give it as player he plays
g4 we have H captures on g4 bishop
characters in g4 now attacking even
chokes Queen and you know would a cool
head event you just place Queen captures
on f6 and if he doesn't mind giving Gary
the open a file to go for the attack as
he is even shocked we have a rope to f8
by Gary and Queen to h4 and rh5 event to
place Bishop to g5 preparing Bishop to
e7 he does want to exchange this bishop
we have rocked rocked eight seven and we
have rook to e3 event she wants to
double up on the e-file which rugby t1
and he will have some ideas of rook rook
to e8 if this ever becomes possible
because this bishop is still not
allowing this King any squares so Gary
doesn't like this he plays a bishop to
see it immediately and he wants to
exchange this bishop so Bishop captures
on c8 King captures on c8 and we have
rook BT 1 now we want to doubles up on
the e-file we have Queen to g6 and now
Bishop to e7
Bishop captures on e7 rook captures an
e7 and Queen captures and c2 and ok Gary
Gary Gary spawn back that he went rogue
who grabbed here on f6 and you want to
place a queen to g3 and well
unfortunately Gary doesn't have time to
grab this a to pawn as eventually is
threatening checkmate here on on c7 so
we have rook captures
seven rookie actors any seven once more
and again if I 2 is threatening
checkmate on c7 and well there is only
one way to stop this of course a Giri
place between the c1 which check would
have pink to h2 and now went to a four
only way to defend it and eventually in
this position place the best move
he plays f3 and this is extremely good
for white if if Giri would trade Queens
here for example queen capture screen
captures while eventually a van trucks
rook is occupying the only open file
here and well this H bone is pretty weak
there are there are ideas like rock to
rock the e5 here attacking both bones
and you want to would enjoy this
position very much
so after this f3 move giri played a 5 we
have worked the e5 now now attacking
both bonds and well probably best idea
for giri here was to play something like
the Queen to d2 and there are no more
ideas of rook to e7 to threaten
checkmate as now Queen captures and c3
would be possible and now this another
Queen is defending this c7 pawn but
after this rope - if I move and I
haven't watched the live coverage so I
don't know was the Sablan drew by giri
or you know did he just miss an idea but
he played a queen to f7
and now defending both of this both of
these bones but he want to place Queen
to h3 with check and after King to be 70
plays rook captures on age 5 and now we
find chip is a pawn up so we have a for
rook th7 attacking the Queen we have
Queen to f4 check blocking with the
Queen Queen to g3a3 and we have Queen
Queen captures on f4 by a bunch of rock
captures on f4 and well okay this pawn
on a3 it does seem like he got very far
but if I'd replace rook back to e7 he
assumed this open file once again with
his rook and well this is a much better
position for revenge or he's upon up and
well we all know how a magic allows well
as the grind does end
you know even equal and games let alone
being upon up and games
so okay gear it tries rook to six the
idea has rocked the c6 to grab this c3
pawn but he want to stop this if he
plays rook to e3
we have rocked h6 check King to g1 King
to a6 Gary wants to get his king now to
b5 + c4 and well we have f4 by a man
choke because you know best bonds must
be pushed that's the role he plays c5
here and even took place f5 and in this
position onigiri actually resigned the
game as well whatever he plays White's
bones are simply much faster for example
if if you play something like a rook to
f6
then simply rook to f3 and well this G
pawn is coming up the board
why is much better here and playing
something like C capture Santi for
doesn't really achieve anything for
black sea captures 94c capture sandy for
and the idea is still the same and even
if think to b5 trying to trying to grab
some points with the King again g4 is
much faster for white so after this f5
move onigiri resigned the game and we'll
see tomorrow
Gary has the white pieces he von Schuch
has the black pieces but as we've seen
in the Avengers game against Vladimir
Kramnik
event Rick really doesn't mind playing
with the black pieces so yeah the Chuck
is closer and closer and closer to that
a World Cup final match we'll see how it
goes so I hope you enjoyed this game
thank you all for watching as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and I will see you soon